we begin here this morning with a
dangerous situation involving russia
ukraine and the west president biden
says he's convinced
russia's president vladimir putin has
decided to invade ukraine
russia is expected to flex its military
might today as president putin oversees
exercises by the country's nuclear
forces a u.s defense official says
nearly half of russia's troops along the
border are now assuming what's described
as an attack posture moscow maintains it
has no plans to invade president biden
cautioned on friday until there is
military action the door remains open to
a diplomatic solution to defuse the
threat
holly williams begins our coverage in
kiev the capital of ukraine holly good
morning
good morning despite the russian troops
mass near ukraine's borders sparking
fears of an invasion the u.s maintained
for weeks that it did not believe that
russia's president vladimir putin had
made up his mind to attack now in the
last 24 hours the u.s says that
assessment has changed
as president putin oversees military
exercises today by russia's nuclear
forces the kremlin says this shouldn't
worry anyone
on the contrary the u.s and its allies
are bracing for the worst a new land war
in europe
in eastern ukraine in a region
controlled by russian-backed separatists
and where many are ethnically russian
they claim they're the ones threatened
by the ukrainian military local leaders
ordered a mass evacuation to russia
video showed sirens wailing
[Music]
an alleged car bombing and an explosion
affecting a gas pipe
and ukrainian soldiers purportedly
attempting to blow up chlorine cylinders
ukraine's government denies the
allegations the u.s is backing its ally
praising ukrainian forces for showing
restraint a device defies basic logic to
believe the ukrainians would choose this
moment
with well over a hundred and fifty
thousand troops arrayed on its borders
to escalate a year-long conflict
the u.s has been warning for weeks that
russia could stage a violent incident as
a pretext for invasion now it says a
so-called false flag operation may have
already started
all these are consistent with the
playbook the russians have used before
to set up a false justification to act
against ukraine
president biden said the u.s believes
russia will target ukraine's capital
kiev a historic city of around 3 million
i met putin
a few times face to face
this is a very dangerous
political animal
arsene yatsenyuk is the former prime
minister of ukraine
the us has done something very unusual
in this crisis it's gone public with its
fears it's told vladimir putin what he
might do before he perhaps does it was
that the right thing to do completely
why
here is the thing i believe that the
united states launched
an unprecedented
deterrence operation against the russian
invasion
but even that strategy new shipments of
u.s weapons and the threat of
unprecedented sanctions may not be
enough to stop vladimir putin
what will you do if there's an invasion
will you fight
we did it in 2014
we will do it in 2022.
you'll pick up a gun absolutely
things are calm here in kiev as they've
been throughout this crisis many
ukrainians seem determined not to show
if they're intimidated but u.s officials
say if russia invades there could be up
to a hundred thousand civilian
casualties michelle
holly williams on the ground in kiev
ukraine thank you